in order to get into battle school
cadets have to pass a rigorous entrance
exam which includes mathematics
help commander graf grade the next wave
of students tests the last step of a
problem in the matrix multiplication
section is the matrix a times b times c
where a b and c are square matrices
which of the following candidates have
answers that are equivalent to this
expression select all who are right for
any a b and c so select all that apply
so encourage you to pause this video and
think about it which of these
expressions for any square matrices a b
and c
are equivalent to this right over here
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so let's think through each of them so
this one is b a c so they have changed
the order and we've already seen that
matrix multiplication is not commutative
in general and so this will not be true
for any square set of matrices a b and c
so this is not going to be true matrix
multiplication is not commutative
so here you have bernard who says a
times c times b
well we already know that that's going
to be the equivalent to a
c
b which once again they've swapped the
order between the b and the c matrix
multiplication is not commutative you
can't just swap order and expect to get
the same product for any square matrices
a b and c so we could rule that one out
a times b c so we've already seen matrix
multiplication is associative so this is
the same thing
as a times b
times c which of course is the same
thing as a
b c
so what karn has right over here that is
right that is equivalent for any square
matrices a b and c that is equivalent to
a b c
now du cheval let's see now this looks
like a bit of a crazy expression but
let's think it through a little bit
so first of all matrix multiplication as
long as you keep the order right the
distributive property does hold so this
first part right over here is equivalent
to 2. so let me write this down this
one's interesting so we have
we have a
times b
c
plus
a
minus
a squared
so you can actually distribute this a
and i encourage you to prove it for
yourself maybe using some 2x2 matrices
for for simplicity and so this is going
to be
equal to
this part right here is going to be a
b c
plus a a a times a which we could write
as a squared and then we're going to
subtract
a squared
well these two things are going to
cancel out they're going to end up being
the zero matrix and if you take the zero
so these are going to be the zero matrix
right over here and if you take the zero
matrix and add it to abc
you're just going to end up with you're
just going to end up with a
b c
so this one was a little bit tricky this
one actually is equivalent
so this one so this one is right
and this one is right and then here this
is a times b plus c so this is kind of a
kind of kind of kind of nutty right over
here this is they're not even
multiplying b and c so this one's
definitely not going to be the true for
all mate square matrices a b and c